(SINGING) Last night
I was lost in time--
Excuse me, Mr. Reeves?
I noticed I didn't
get a callback.
Look, you're just not the right
kind of girl for this show.
But--
(SINGING) Like a movie in my--
I don't want you to quit
when things get hard.
You're talented, you're smart.
You can do anything.
(SINGING) When I look out--
Your song is blowing up.
You should see the
reactions online.
"I'm so sick of
wannabe pop stars."
Is that it?
He's probably just
some dumb online troll.
Didn't stop five
people from liking it.
[GASPS]
[SCREAMING]
(SINGING) Remember there's--
You're the amazing Holly Hobbie.
You need to take control
of the narrative.
What are you doing?
Signing up.
OK.
See you there.
See ya.
[CHEERING]
(SINGING) You and I --
Now introducing,
singer-songwriter Holly Hobbie.
(SINGING) Remember that
there's more to life.
[CHEERING]
Now, that is beautiful.
(SINGING) Remember
there's more to life.
[CHEERING]